we live in in time you know of post
truth this is the first thing and you
know that
Oxford Dictionary included that word
into into dictionary recently this year
and because of an enormous circulation
of that word before it meant something
else
it means the truth after the actual
event today it it penetrated everywhere
and it means that truth could be
distorted that it doesn't matter facts
do not matter but our feelings are hurt
feelings or whatever so and of course
technology helps a lot to that so today
you can find on internet I mean people
talking about Hegel and not being
philosophers but cooks or you know the
people teaching you how to do a makeup
and not being cosmeticians so what
happened and I noticed that at the
beginning of this new Croatia that the
key word is in fact which nobody ever
mentioned is the professionalization
that is what happens when two German
came into power in Croatia and that's
what happened when Milosevic came into
power in Serbia so now after so many
years that what means what does it mean
the professionalization that means that
let's say all the judges who were Serbs
in Croatia they were fired all
journalists who were Serbs or who were
Yugoslavs or concern
to be anti-creationist and that they
were fired all the all the professors at
the university who didn't support
Croatian nationalistic politics they
were fired so journalists radio people
writers intellectuals professors even
doctors who were Serbs in hospitals they
were fired and and now after 25 years we
are in fact confront we are confronted
with the results that that I not being
the politician not being a political
scientist not being country Paula gist
not being sociologist I became a sort of
an expert on nationalism I must say that
why I so heavily took all that case of
fall of Yugoslavia and everything is
because it is fair to say that I'm post
war child I was born in 1949 and that
means that somehow all my generation it
grew in the shadow of Second World War
that also means that somehow we induce
the coordinates of good and evil in that
respect evil were fascists and good were
anti-fascist good was my father because
he was 17 when he joined Tito's
partisans and bad were enemies and they
were Germans so that's how it was very
simple to sort of live in in that
polarized world where we sort of knew
what is good and what is bad today
children they do not I very own they
today children they don't know the
difference in between image of Mickey
Mouse and image of Hitler anymore that
they don't know what is what I picked
somehow the ideological package of
socialist Yugoslavia and that
ideological package was sort of pretty
simple the main formula was that we
should cherish Brotherhood that unity
like an apple of our eye that's how I
learned when I was very young
what does it mean Apple of of an hi and
that was apparently that sentence slogan
belongs to to Tito
they say also it was education was
something which was a crucial part of
that package ideological package and it
was even sort of I mean the knowledge
and knowledge and knowledge that with
that with the crucial thing and I
remember how my mother would always say
for somebody that his study teens were
born and that was something which was
the hunt the highest thing one could
imagine and when I was a little girl I I
promised myself that I would study in
Sobran because I like to I could not I
misspell it so - so bran and then that I
would of course be famous like Minu drew
you don't know who my new drew was that
was a little girl she was 10 when she
published her first book
and and she was globally well known but
then she disappeared and and of course
later on came some other idols like they
were apparently all connected with
France and I didn't have anything to do
with France that I will one day live on
monsaert so that I will study at Sobran
and that I will have a boyfriend as ugly
and as as smart as Jean Paul Chartres I
also studied comparative literature and
Russian language and literature Russian
language and literature not because not
because yugoslavs were forced to learn
Russian language the opposite because we
were enemies so so I studied it because
I was very much interested in Russian
avant-garde and I studied I studied debt
and I also I must I must admit that I
must that my critics in Croatia would
call pretty clumsily like nationally
colorblind I really as my parents never
ever mentioned such things I I would
always in all my documents I would
declare myself as you was loved because
my father was a ghost Lance and my
mother although she never denied her
Bulgarian the bulgarian family I mean
she was us loved to sew so somehow I
didn't have that that that problem of of
self positioning and yes it was for the
first time I've heard such stories when
somebody else would define me as
Croatian or in 1997
in 71 during the Croatian Spring which
was the rehearsal political risk Herzl
what will come twenty years later in
1991 so then people would ask me Who am
I and I would be surprised hearing when
I said that I'm a Yugoslav then my
friends would say yeah but all the Serbs
in Croatia would declare themselves
yugoslavs I nevertheless I didn't pay
attention I didn't know what does it
mean I also I must admit that many
people will tell you from being from
former Yugoslavia that they knew things
would happen oh I always knew that we
are going to have a new war or something
like that
I didn't I admit honestly I didn't
simply because I was rational and as we
know I mean fascism one of
characteristics according to Umberto Eco
or fascism is irrationality so my
rational view was that people are not so
crazy that they are going to kill each
other or go into the war or anything
just because of politics that things
could be solved in a in a civilized
manner but never the less I was wrong
and in 1991 when all of that started I
was simply appalled I was also invited
in September of 1991 to come to
Amsterdam because my books were
published here and I used a little
moment when there was a ceasefire and
although banks were closed and I
also embassies were closed for visa
airports who closed I took a train and I
came to Amsterdam instead of one week I
spend in in Amsterdam three weeks and I
managed to get my American visa because
the next year starting from January in
1982 I was supposed to teach one
semester at Western University
Connecticut in the States so when I came
back to Zagreb things were changed all
my friends I remember clearly we laughed
- such figures like Milosevic and
Koosman suddenly nobody laughed and
things became quite serious and I could
see this not even polarization but home
organization and how people became one
collective body and that was this
language today mentioned we suddenly I
mean it was not my friend Nana or my
friend Maya but they would declare
themselves as we we cross okay and and
then I wrote because at that time it was
it was a souvenir I mean new Croatian
state was producing all sorts of things
ideology most of all but also with the
ideology souvenirs that the ideology
should be somehow swallowed in a sweeter
manner so at that time in Croatia you
could find the souvenirs tins cans very
much resembling coca-cola
cans and and they had Croatian quarter
farms there and and then it said it was
a slogan on on those they were empty
cans a souvenir can cans and it said
clean crashing air and and I wrote a
little essay about that about mr. clean
and I just counted what mr. clean is
cleaning in Croatia was cleaning at the
very beginning in the year of 1982 so
these things were obvious I mean to
everybody but nobody really found them
appalling or shocking so libraries were
cleaned off
books books who were found in the
garbage or even books who burned because
we had that too in the year of 1992-93
and so Bukit seat book aside that
according to the instructions of then
Minister of Culture all the libraries in
crash should be reorganized okay meaning
that books in Cyrillic letters that
books written by Serbs books written by
communists books written by sympathizers
of Yugoslavia books written by William
Shakespeare in Cyrillic letters or
translated by Serbian translator out out
out
teachers would participate in that too
the librarians would participate in that
too
my books were found on the garbage -
according to the rapids of some
journalists and somebody even suggested
that every book written by a Croatian
pure Croatian author should have a
little sign a traditional Croatian
letter so that the in of course in
colours of Croatian flag that every book
should be marked by that so that from
the first sight you should know who are
crowds and who are the rest
shakespeare's and so okay so what else
was cleaned apart from the books
everything schoolbooks books for the
universities organizations institutions
people got fired and as I told you at
the beginning so that that was cleaned
and even at that time there was a there
was something called spiritual renewal
which simply meant that Croatia as one
body as we as one collective should
become what pew purified what does it
mean purified it meant to get rid of all
communists socialists Yugoslav
multicultural whatever ideas okay
the Great Architect of creation state
Freneau two German together with
Malaysia which I mean I'm taking as an
example Croatia just because it is
portable it's small
transparent and I know it so for me it's
not a state or these are not the people
but this is example I could I could take
any other but this is the one I know the
best okay so um so that means that
architect of Croatian state [ __ ] tooth
Minh he totally relied on independent
state of Croatia during the Second World
War when Croatia was Nazi puppet state
okay with everything
one Nazi state should have with its
policy culture ideology and
concentration camps for Jews Serbs
Roma's and so forth including language
institutions ideology even what was
returned even as symbols like the same
coat of arms the same Flags the same
money and the same name for the money
many words from this newly invented for
the purposes of Nazi state of Croatia
were returned in new Croatia in 1881
they penetrated into the language and of
course the major thing is the
restoration of history history so good
guys partisans they should be burned and
deleted Yugoslavia deleted totally and
prohibited and what should be
resurrected as a value and as a
tradition is a creation Nazi puppet
state so the story about restoration
it lasts already a quarter of century it
lasts 25 years because Croatia became
independent 1981 we are today 2016 so it
is exactly quarter of century
you